أريدك فقط أن تعرف أن
شعب المملكة المتحدة يدعم
شعب أوكرانيا ويدعمك في
معركتك وأنا مقتنع تمامًا
أنه يمكنك الفوز وأنك ستفوز
شكرًا جزيلاً لك جاكلين وسلافو
بكاء
لذا بمجرد أن نتعاون  القوة في
موقعها ، نحن بصدد المضي قدمًا ،
لقد كنت ألتقي ببعض من 400
جندي أوكراني موجودون هنا أه
يتم تدريبهم من قبل أه قواتنا
تستعد للذهاب وأه محاربة أوكرانيا
هذا جزء من التزام كبير لدينا
صُنع لتدريب القوات الأوكرانية
نريد تدريب حوالي 10 آلاف منهم
على مدى الأشهر الأربعة القادمة التي تأتي على
رأس الاستثمار أه الذي نقوم به في
أه دعم الأوكرانيين
بالسلاح 6900 سلاحًا مضادًا للدبابات و 120
مركبة مدرعة وأشياء كثيرة أخرى
إلى جانب تضمين الآن
أنظمة إطلاق الصواريخ المتعددة أه
أن الأمريكيين الألمان وغيرهم ممن
نقدمهم بدأوا بالفعل في إحداث
فرق ونأمل في مسار هذا
الإحماء